they said bats had bit bitten people and
urinated on people and that's what they
think caused the leak and then they
quickly retract this we got rid of it
because probably the CCP came in and
said do you enjoy living and they're
like we do it's like we didn't get rid
of it yeah of course well the guy that
top scientist that went missing that
asked a question even asked a question
and you know then yeah obviously you saw
this stuff in Congressional testimony
during Peak it was like the fouchy
emails versus the fauci TV appearances
you know on the cover of like Vogue
magazine or whatever the hell he was
doing like
they were literally a contra like you
cannot so was he lying to the American
public or was he lying to his colleagues
in medicine because they were literally
Polar Opposites one of them has to be a
lie no everything so who was he lying to
it like yeah science I'm not sure if
you're aware of this he is the science
besides and again because that became
the religion of the left and he was The
High Priestess of that religion you
could not you could not question it